>>M EAIE
BAE R G ARRESTED FOR
TOE FEAR VIOLENCE AFTE
SOCIAL MEDIST, TAKE OUR NATION
THERE'S SO QST HOW
DO YOUTE
UNPRECEDENTED MOMENT?M JOIN    U
>>O MANY DIFFERENTCS AAY
YOU VER WE'VE NEVER SEEN A SITU
ENG ABOUL PROTESTORS.T THAT L
WHAT HAPPEONRY 6
WH THEMAISSED BACK
THEN.
AC
THE AK WHAT IS  HERE FROM FEDERH
ENINGS FORVERAL DA. THINGS THAT,
REDEORT OFING ON HIS TO TS, TO B
S THAT IABSOLUTELYE SOONESLD S
ESO BE
INDICT'TF THAT WOULD
NEXT WEEK.COT
NEXT WEEK.
EVAT I
PLAYING  WHAT FORCEMENT HERE IS
GI, BRINGING
BRTH PRESIDENT
INTO TE.S CRET SERVICEEN
S SECURITY AND THAT NDRT OF HIS
NEXT WEEK.PPEN
A LOL AT
ENFORCEMTR FIGUROUT F THIS AND
PROTECTINGESIDENANYBODY WHO COM
WORK AROUND HERE. F AND THE E A
>> STAY WITH SHIMOWAO BRININA E
ANDRAS OD THDENT
CALLOR
POSSIBLE INDICTMEN
?HENT BRACING
L, PAM,
IF YA SECURITY
PROFESSIONAL, LAW RCU HAVE TO B
BYG THAT THE PRESIDENT
STL HAS THE SAME SORT OFWA
ER H
SUID LEADING  6th.
SO THEY  OF THSTEPY WOULD NUARY
THERE IS CHATTER
ONLINEN THOSE PLACESREHERMER PR
ADHEADHERENTS D
ASSUME TNG TR INANTA
SORT OFT THERE IS
IN CONVENING IN YOR Y
OTHER PLACE AROUND AOT
IONEEP ENT D D NEW
EXPERIEN ID CONTROL.
THERE'S NO PLACE IN THE COUNTRY
YORK CITY.EW
TH'L WTEE LL BE
CETO SAW PPEN ON NUGHDYTHAT HE
THAT HE DOES IVERY DIFFERENTOFT.
6t TRESIDENT AND
SUPPORRSANY DA T
ABOUT COMING TD.WAS A T
NEEDED TO BE THERE.
TO COMLE WHO WAN
WILL, OF LEGITIMATD
ALL T
ADDE MIH K PUTS LAWEM
OFALS IN AE BETTERT THEYAV PLARR
SO MANYNS
THE FIRST ME BECAUSEUNPRECEDENT?
NHATTAA.WHEN
ER IND
NOTIYS FORFENDANT, FOR PERSO
WHO'S GOING TO B
HE
TTNE,
COUALLY ATA.ROVER TO THE
K THE
ROE HALLCOURTHOUSE INTO THE COUE
HAPPEN HERE.MA REASONS, BUT O PH
JUST WANT TTE ONEINMSF ALST AND
HINGE QUIET DIE TO
N UP ON JANUARh.
THEY'VEN RUNNING DOW
THERE'S NOA LOT OF CONCERN FOR.
THE FORM
SAFELY, THAT IS METHINTHNLG >>
YOSO MUCH.
E
HEADLINEISRY OF THE
WOAT THE CENTES GED COVERUP.
STEPHANIE CLIFFORDS WHTHE NAME O
orter: HE HAD  S WT FI 60, S WYD
TRUMP EDE,S NEW BABY-
>> A Y W
.
>>ep
DET EVER
>>G T
D TO BNG UP H E TIME, THAT'SU W.
OUISIANA, STEPHANIE CLT
T IN TEAMS
BY HER, SHE THOUGHP MIGHT HELP
D,ERIONS OF ANFA HINM AS 2016
SA$1KEEP QUI HIM.
IED ANY KNOWOF THA
2018.
>> DID YOUNOW OUT THE
DANIELS? PAYMY
>>O.r: BUT THAT SAME
SUMMER --
>> DID YOU KNOW ABOUT THE YMENT?
ATER ON I >> HER HADD AT TIMES
FOR E, AT ON
GNS G ANY
AFFAIR TOO
F IT WASRUU >> BECAUSE IADO CHO
>> Reporter: NO ONE WAPU
A GUN TO YOUR HEAD NOT
>> IN FACTTHE T SENTENCE
USAS, THEY
FEL O FERENT
WAYS.
>> Reporter: FURTHER CO
THE LEPAYOE FROM  FUNDS TION OFC
L COAT MONEY AND THAT TRKN
ITHERS IS
ORBIT SAID NO WAT S NO
SORRY.>> RepteERT DAYS HE
LEVEIELS AS
HE INSISTE, I DID
NOTHINWRG BERSE
NEVER HA AFFAI